President Trump is steamed with China
following a report it has been secretly
selling oil to North Korea in violations
of United Nations sanctions a South
Korean paper published what it said were
US spy satellite photos showing Chinese
ships delivering oil to North Korean
ships at sea President Trump tweeted
today quote caught red-handed very
disappointed that China is allowing oil
to go into North Korea there will never
be a friendly solution to the North
Korean problem if this continues to
happen end quote and tonight in an
interview with the New York Times the
president says he's quote been soft in
quote on China over trade in hopes that
its government will pressure North Korea
to abandon its nuclear weapons program
let's discuss the implications with Fox
News national security and foreign
affairs analyst Walid Phares in Orlando
Florida and joining us from San
Francisco California's attorney and
foreign policy analyst Ari aramesh thank
you gentlemen both for joining us you've
both been out outspoken on a number of
foreign policy issues but Ari let me
start with you that the president I mean
he had a pretty good year on foreign
policy for a rookie don't you think did
he I think not know the president has
had a number of major Fiasco's first and
foremost let me start by saying this our
allies are worried about us and our
enemies which ala which Ally do you
think is worried about it which lig
thinks Germany Germany the United
Kingdom Germany's Angela Merkel who the
president would not even shake her hand
at the White House Angela the British
where we now have a debate whether the
president is even invited to a wedding
to a royal wedding for Prince Harry no
no Jason wedding Jason that is not my
concern but it might reflect my Jason my
concern of China no I I did bring it up
so let me finish the point Jason Jason
my concern is that America is no longer
respected under Donald J Trump that is
my problem okay you're entitled to your
opinion I happen to disagree with that
but let's talk about Sharia first say I
want to talk about China
in South Korea in North Korea because it
is a very difficult proposition here we
have spy satellite photos reportedly out
showing that North Korea is in China are
trading fuel on a ship let's go to dr.
Ferris what do you make of this and what
the president's approach has been
particularly as it relates to North
North Korea what we have first of all
the daily approach that basically
generates debates about what we see what
we don't see the pictures of photos and
then you have a strategic approach and
the strategic approach basically the
novelty of the Trump administration is
that the eastern Asian alliance is back
and running that's the most important
point Japan South Korea other players
we've seen this in his Asian tour and
that is sending basically strong signals
to China the deployment of task forces
which has generated congressmen a
unanimous vote of the Security Council
including China and Russia and of course
our other allies against North Korea on
the one hand on the other hand yes the
Chinese are not yet completely convinced
that they got a move 100% in this issue
they don't know they don't have answers
on if that regime collapses in North
Korea who replace him 100% Pro Chinese
neutral will be South Korea so I think
that the more diplomatic work with China
on the one hand but on the ground in the
East Asian alliance I think it's very
clear that there's a pressure coming
from that side okay so Ari
there was a strong vote you've got to
admit in the United Nations where they
made a pretty strong statement nikki
Haley I gotta admit it did a pretty good
job of helping to bring people along but
given the spy satellite photos that you
see here given the situation that we're
in today what do you recommend Jason do
you think that the president should be
doing in this particular case Jason if
you don't cut me off or interrupt me for
30 seconds and I promise you not to like
the floor with anybody but give me 30
seconds here's a problem okay well we
have a unanimous vote we have a
unanimous vote in the UN Security
Council that is because North Korea is
an international prior first and
foremost but let Tillerson be Tillerson
let him do his job the president can't
wake up every more
and tweet nonsense the president can't
wake up every morning after planning his
golf game and after planning his little
vacations cannot miss handle and
misinterpret and ignore intelligence
reports and intelligence briefing so
what what's he do you think he's not
know what does he what do you
specifically think he should be doing
given this current satellite photos
you're looking at I'm like we are today
what I think the president should be
doing at this point well the president
for the first and foremost the president
should have not endeared the Chinese
when he shared some chocolate cake but
I'm in Mario Lago and secondly he should
turn up the heat on the Chinese the
Chinese have more leverage on the North
Koreans than anybody in the region or in
the world for that matter
third he should ignore the calls coming
from Russia and from Sergey Lavrov
that's a Russian foreign minister who
try to mediate between the u.s. and
North Korea this is not a u.s. North
Korea problem this is a North Korea
versus the rest of the world problem
okay duck bottom right is what the
president Jason Farrelly I did you were
the chairman of the you were the
chairman of the Oversight Committee yes
this is really you got a mess okay time
fair you got allocate time fairly you
know and you're ferrous dr. good luck go
run it run it thank you thank you dr.
Farris tell me what you think the
president should be doing in this
particular case well first of all he is
doing and we cannot rely on one evening
news report about what the Chinese are
doing only this is the Chinese talking
to President Trump and his
administration but he's talking to them
as well what do you think the Chinese
war room or for that matter of the North
Korean War Rooms are looking at at his
tweets in the morning no they're looking
at the movement of the task forces that
are being operational in those areas
they're looking at the joint exercise
between Japan South Korea and of course
they're looking at the growth of that
international coalition that wants to
isolate North Korea China today is not
China of the 50s they have a financial
interest around the world and the action
is around
not just what's happening between China
and the United States bilaterally but
also internationally as well so I
recommend that they flare Trump for a
fool while he don't run I got it I got
it there I got a little later you try to
vitiate Trump for I'm getting old I'm
gonna try to wish you a Happy New Year